der fall maddie mccann ist mit
ziemlicher wahrscheinlichkeit der größte
entführungsfall der welt
[Musik]
ein mensch verschwindet von einer zur
anderen sekunden und es gibt überhaupt
keine spur
[Musik]
was ist mit dir passiert ihr davon aus
dass das mädchen tot ist die fünf
medieninteresse diese weltweite
beobachten dieses falls das ist
angeboren getan
da ist ein ärztepaar mit einem
bildhübschen hin dass in diesem sicheren
raum urlaub spurlos verschwindet
das ausmaß dieses verbrechens ist so
groß dass es uns 14 jahre danach
im grunde noch rund um die uhr vor genau
einem jahr der paukenschlag man amüsiert
fest wenn sie diesen mann sinken
mein name ist kai feldhaus ich bin
reporter von bild in berlin ich grüße
sie
wahnvorstellung obwohl sind das manchmal
schnell daher ist wenn ich schon immer
krank gemeldet es gibt jetzt ganz
plötzlich einen deutschen verdächtigen
und damit war total klar
die nächsten tage wird es nicht so viele
freiminuten geben
[Musik]
nein
der schweiz
ende
opera 10
[Musik]
ich war damals korrespondent für bild in
london an bord im büro über britische
nachrichtenkanäle erfahren dass da was
passiert ist und das hat dann einen
nächsten tag und auch in den tagen
darauf die nachrichten in england
komplett dominiert
dann ist auch hier langsam
durchgesickert ist dass ein verbrechen
von ungewöhnlichem ausmaßes
ich kann
schwerlich über reißen wie viele artikel
ich zum fall maddie schon geschrieben
habe
dutzende
wenn die naiv schau und mal und meinen
namen eingeben und dann fast nur daran
was in wild erschienen ist im bild am
sonntag und auch bild online dann kommen
wir wahrscheinlich auf 100 artikeln
wahrscheinlich mehr
die große frage die im raum steht ist er
der mann der diese verbrechen begangen
hat dass das was alle wissen wollen was
die staatsanwaltschaft wissen will was
die verteidigung wissen was im grunde
auch die ganze öffentlichkeit wissen was
ich wissen möchte wer ist christian roth
wer ist dieser mann könnte er die tat
begangen haben was treibt ihn
rund um den fall überhaupt zu verstehen
und auch die anfänge des falles muss man
nach portugal fahren dorthin wo alles
begonnen hat
[Musik]
kaum jemand kennt den fall von anfang an
so gut wie und samara
[Musik]
und noch einmal hat die ermittlungen im
fall maddie mccann von anfang an geführt
er war damals kriminalkommissar und
nachdem er aus dem polizeidienst
entfernt wurde nach dem fall abgezogen
würde den reporter den ruhestand
geschickt wurde in den großraum lissabon
zurückgezogen lebt jetzt hier in der
nähe und hat von sich aus vorgeschlagen
dass wir uns hier treffen
[Musik]
nachdem er von seinen aufgaben entbunden
wurde und ein buch veröffentlich hatte
dass wir sehr viel unruhe gesorgt hat
mit den medien gebrochen also hat sich
überall falsch dargestellt gefühlt das
heißt eigentlich redet er nicht mehr
deswegen bin ich jetzt sehr dankbar dass
er bei uns noch mal eine ausnahme machen
müsste gerne von dem was er von dieser
theorie dass christian meeh der täter
ist das nach 14 jahren plötzlich darauf
taucht der ist gewesen sein soll ich
wüsste gerne ob er den auf dem radar
hatte und was er jetzt dazu sagt
[Musik]
zehn jahre war an wenn wir jetzt
zurückdenken an den abend des dritten
mai 2007 können sie sich noch erinnern
wo sie waren als der anruf kam dass
maddie mccann verschwunden ist
als kripochef ging ich nicht gleich zum
tatort das macht immer ein kollege wir
gingen an diesem fall genauso heran an
einen diebstahl als wäre etwas gestohlen
worden wie sind die täter an den tatort
gelangt wie sind sie wieder weg gibt es
einbruchspuren oder fingerabdrücke das
war im nachhinein ein fehler
hat sich zum ersten mal an dem
appartement in praia da luz spur
gefahren bin saß nur ein journalist mit
einem laptop im auto kurz danach war
niemand mehr da und nur stunden später
war es als ginge die welt unter ein
unglaublicher zirkus wurde aufgefahren
wir hatten überhaupt keine möglichkeiten
mehr ungestört und software zu arbeiten
und warum all das es gibt mehrere
faktoren aber der wichtigste ist sicher
der wunsch der eltern alles zu tun um
ihr image
[Musik]
im zuge der ermittlungen 2007 auch der
name christian begegnet
der name christian weber auf meiner
liste von menschen die ein gewisses
pädophiles profil aufweisen an der
gesamten algarve boden teams gebildet
man hat an seine tür geklopft aber er
war nicht zu hause
jetzt kommt aber plötzlich deutschland
ins spiel die staatsanwaltschaft in
braunschweig sagt es gebe materielle
beweise dafür dass ist christian b wir
kennen entführt und ermordet hat
der deutsche staatsanwalt sollte nicht
ständig behaupten dass er etwas gegen
christian hruby in der hand hat dann
klagt ihn an ringen vor gericht und dann
erklären ihre wie jemand in das abhaken
und eingebrochen ist ohne fingerabdrücke
oder spuren von handschuhen zu verlassen
erkläre mir warum gab es keine
einbruchspuren war das fenstergriffe
warum waren dort nur die fingerabdrücke
der mutter zu finden
[Musik]
das gespräch mit uns alle war sinnvoll
wichtig dass es auch noch mal die andere
seite dieses falles beleuchtet und das
klo amaral jetzt ganz klar sagt dieser
mann das ist unsinn
das ist der ideale verdächtige den sie
immer gesucht haben und der hat füllt
jetzt nur diese rolle das erweitert
zumindest den blickwinkel auf den fall
dass man nicht vergessen sollte
christian b ist verdächtig aber noch
längst nicht angeklagt
[Musik]
ich bin immer wieder
selbstständig an diesem zwiespalt zu
sehen die paradiese schönen range ist zu
verstehen dass dieser ort jetzt
stellvertretend steht für eines der
größten verbrechen die
kriminalgeschichte das fällt mir immer
wieder schwer aber ist es auch ebenso
wichtig dann immer mal hier zu sein
[Musik]
ich war 2017 das vorletzte mal hier
und zwar zum zehnten jahrestag des
verschwindens von berlin erkämpft und
wir haben damals versucht nochmal zu
rekonstruieren wie dieser abend
abgelaufen ist nach schilderung der
eltern
am abend des dritten mal 2007 17 matt
lanter eltern hier in dieser tapas bar
auf der anderen seite des pools beim
abend ist das appartement war von der
tapas-bar auszusehen man konnte terrasse
sehen den eingang
ist der vorletzte abend ihres urlaubs
hier in praia da luz in portugal die
mccanns sitzen zusammen mit drei
befreundeten familien die erwachsenen
wechseln sich alle halbe stunde ab und
nach die schlafenden kindern zu sehen
gegen 22 uhr ist metals mutter kate an
der reihe sie verlässt also ich
tapas-bar läuft am pool entlang um zu
appartement 5 das ocean club zu gelangen
das hier im erdgeschoss dieses gebäudes
nicht um sie im appartement zu kommen
muss kate mccann durch die rezeption und
über diese kleine straße laufen
also kann ich mir gern um 22 uhr das
zimmer ihrer tochter betritt stellt
zunächst fest dass sie ein windzug
entgegen auch bemerkt dann
das mittel in nicht mehr im bett nicht
dieses fenster das jetzt zehn jahre
später verbittert ist
steht weit offen kurz darauf ist sie
schreiend wieder raus gelaufen und hat
gerufen werden take off take berlin ist
weg sie ist verschwunden jemand hat sie
mitgenommen bis heute fehlt von methling
kennen jede spur
wir können eltern ihr kleines kind immer
partner schlaf lassen werden sie essen
gehen ich glaube wenn man sich das vor
ort anschaut und das vor ort erläutert
dann versteht man dass das gar nicht so
abwegig ist
die tapas bar liegt auf dem gelände des
ocean club sie ist teil der anlage von
der tapas-bar aus das kann man in dem
video erkennen können sie auf die
terrasse ihres appartements schauen
jetzt zehn fünfzehn jahre später nachdem
so etwas passiert ist kann man sagen wie
kann man denn und die kinder schlafen
lassen und alleine und so ich halte das
gar nicht für so wahnsinnig abwegig die
eltern waren keine 50 meter luftlinie
entfernt sie haben regelmäßig
nachgeschaut jetzt im nachhinein wenn
man weiß dass sowas hier passieren kann
dann ist es einfach in der vorwürfe zu
machen
was man hier für wundervolle urlaub
verbringen kann wie sorglos auch die
menschen hier sind das über einzubringen
mit dem was hier passiert
dann bleibt am ende eine große frage
zurück wer ist so wahnsinnig
während der urlaubszeit abends um 22 uhr
der 21 30 durch ein erdgeschossfenster
in ein bewohntes appartement
einzusteigen um dort ein kind zu
entführen diese frage
die muss ich mal ein experte stellen
[Musik]